notre témoin du jour c'est maître Joseph
Cohen Saban l'avocat de Bruno Vandelli
il va revenir sur les accusations de
Yanis Marchall contre son client
rappelez-vous avanthier Yanis Marchal a
publié des storyies troublantes dans
lesquelles il accuse Bruno Vandelli
d'agression sexuelle sur mineur hier il
nous a annoncé qu'il allait porter
plainte on regarde ensemble la story d'
Yanis Marchall vous avez donné les
dernières infos de cette affaire qui est
incroyable et on en parle ensemble
regardez coucou ça va ça fait longtemps
ça fait 20 ans eu tu peux porter plainte
pour diffamation tant que tu veux on
s'est tous retrouv
on parle tous de toi entre nous on sait
tous à quel point tu as bousi notre vie
et on va s'occuper de toi je vais
m'occuper de toi personnellement dis-toi
juste que ce sera moi le le mec l'homme
responsable de tout ça il est temps la
liste est trop longue et ça suffit en
fait donc bonne chance prépare-toi parce
que je seraai sans pitié et vraiment je
veux que tu le saches je seraai s
piter alors Bruno Bruno a régi sur
Instagram il fit une période euh euh
alors on on voit rien on peut le mettre
là fait une période être vivant c'était
travailler se passionner euh toujours
chercher à être meilleur humain au
travers de sa vie aujourd'hui on est
avocat juge bourreau sur des réseaux
sociaux sans aucun discernement ni réel
savoir il faut se donner son moment de
gloire et de perfection en pointant
autrui ou en faisant sa propre publicité
ne croyez pas que ce jeu puisse
m'intéresser mon avocat lui fait de la
justice une vérité ma plainte contient
certainement ce qu'il faut envers cette
mascarade qui voudrait me faire passer
pour un monstre euh prenez le temps
d'écouter en place et lieu de suivre une
mode un besoin de reconnaissance oui un
chemin qui allégera votre conscience oui
je n'ai pas à baisser la tête faire euh
face à la personne que je suis c'est
c'est cré petit hein et vous avez encore
une fois méprisé la présomption
d'innocence donc mon avocat dès ce soir
saura poser les mots dire que ce que
certains ont sûrement besoin d'entendre
là où d'autres ne le veulent pas je vous
laisse face à votre tout savoir menacer
quelqu'un n'est pas preuve de votre
force mais de votre votre faiblesse je
ne menace pas j'agis peut-être autrement
que vous mais je crois à un moment donné
aux valeurs de ce que notre justice est
en capacité de décider je remercier
l'excellent maître Joseph Cohen Saban
d'être avec nous cette affaire elle est
incroyable Yanis Marchal a déposé
plainte contre votre client non non pour
l'instant non non toujours pas d'accord
c'est juste par les réseaux sociaux en
fait qui s'est manifesté ouais
alors c'est la première fois que votre
client est accusé de de tel
fait pas tout à fait la première fois
car il y a eu il y a quelques semaines
au mois de décembre une première
salve d'attaque contre lui mais c'était
pareil de l'Instagram ou du TikTok ou je
ne sais quoi d'accord mais pas de d' pas
de plantete ah non non non
jamais pas à ma connaissance j'ai
entendu dire puisque j'ai j'ai Suu une
interview qu'il a donné depuis
l'Australie que il y avait eu des
plaintes par d'autres mais qui n'avait
rien donné voilà voilà où jeen suis
d'accord il connaît Yanis depuis combien
de temps il connait Yanis depuis combien
de temps Bruno Vandelli pardonnez-moi le
connait depuis combien de temps
moi conna depuis combien 30 ans 30 ans
d'accord ah oui donc est tout petit
ouais parce que connu ils se sont
rencontrés comment dans le
cadreesss son professeur de danse il
était mineur à l'époque Yanis c'est ça
Gill oui il était mineur et puis donc
lui il dénonce une agression sexuelle
alors aujourd'hui selon mes informations
il a expliqué que H personnes l'avait
contacté pour décrire des faits
similaires est-ce que vous avez la
connaissance vous d'autres personnes qui
s'agrègeraient à Yanis Marchall on m'a
parlé d'une plainte déposée par une
maman en 2015 à propos de son enfant de
14 ans est-ce que ça vous avez des info
plainte déposée peut-être mais plainte
qui a donné lieu à quoi que ce soit
certainement non ça j'en serai forcément
informé par conséquent là non
euh par ailleurs en ce qui concerne des
gens qui se sont regroupés vous avez vu
sans doute comme moi qu'il a écrit un
peu partout pour dire pour faire une
recherche de
témoins j'ignore ce qu'il a pu avoir
comme témoin qu'il a pu obtenir comme
témoignage moi ce que je sais c'est
qu'on est proche d'un procès mais c'est
même plus le procès stalinien on a
quelqu'un qui écrit je vais déposer
plainte il a toujours pas fait et ça
fait quelques semaines il c'était il y a
de jours sur certains réseaux mais par
ailleurs ça fait sur la région de Cannes
ça fait maintenant depuis plus d'un mois
que que ça tourne on a un feu qui s'est
allumé qui est en train de détruire il
faut le dire parce qu'avec avec ou son
procès il est détruit vendéi hein on le
sait c'est comme ça qui s'est allumé il
y a pas une plainte je ne sais pas ce
qu'on lui reproche c'est les procès de
Moscou ça j'ai si j'avais devant moi une
plainte je viens je vous en parle ou je
viens pas je vous en parle pas je prends
mes responsabilités mais là je ne sais
même pas d'accord c'est fou on me
reproche c'est délirant alors euh ça a
été quoi la réaction de Bruno Vandelli
après les stories de de Yanis il a un
plongeon ouais ah il devient fou il est
sous terre il est huit pieds sous terre
plus personne veut lui parler il se fait
insulter partout voilà qu'est-ce que
vous voule il peut rien faire on se
défend pas c'est quo c'est quoi sa
version à à
Bruno j'ai même pas envie d'en parler je
vais vous dire pourquoi mais je vais en
parler bien entendu je vais pas esquiver
mais j'ai pas envie d'en parler parce
que il essaie de trouver il essaie de
trouver ce qu'on pourrait lui reprocher
alors il est vrai qu'il a eu ce gar ç
son comme comme élève il y a 20 ans
l'élève a 34 ans aujourd'hui il a eu il
a traverser des choses et là je je
balance pas des infos qu'on ne connaît
pas il a écrite lui-même pourquoi il
s'est fait virer TF1 parce qu'il était
toxico il arrivé torché sur les plateaux
j' savais rien c'est lui qui l'a écrit
de la même manière il y a eu plein de
choses qui sont passées dans sa vie
comment voulez-vous que aujourd'hui on
puisse se défendre face à quelqu'un qui
nous parle de d'un truc 30 ans après
c'est quoi la version de Bruno Vandelli
aujourd'hui il il admet l'idée qu'il y a
eu autour des 16 ans de ce garçon un
rapprochement affectif ils étaient
amoureux l'un de l'autre ce qu' admet
d'ailleurs Marchal ad il y a eu ça mais
jamais de ni de de viol ni de choses
comme ça qui d'ailleurs à l'instant où
je vous parle ne lui sont pas reproché
d'accord je me fonde sur ce qui écrit
Marchall il parle pourquoi il dit 14
Ansou 14 ans mais qui vous dit que c'est
14 ans non mais c'est ça non mais il dit
14 ans et que ça s'est terminé à 16 mais
si ça a commencé à 15 et que ça s
terminé à 16 c'est pas pareil c'est pas
c'est pas la même la majorité sexuelle
et C vous votre client il dit 16 et
c'est pour ça que je suis fou furieux de
devoir parler de quelque chose sans base
sans une plainte sans des éléments sans
des données VO merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous vous n tenez au courant de
l'affaire et je saurai comment revenir
vers vous ah oui avec plaisir vous avez
je sais comment revenir vers vous
comment c'est vrai je descends je me
mets sur une plage à Cann et j'appelle
exactement et chopen vous Arve
exactement c'est vrai voilà ben on se
cisera à canne avec grand plaisir vous
inquiétez pas Gill Verdes ne vient
jamais dans cette
[Applaudissements]
région mais mais pas pas Gill bien
heureusement on va passer à l'invité du
soir vous avez regardé le complément
d'enquête sur Jordan Bardella hier ou
pas non vous regardez pas cette émission
non c'est même pas ça c'est je préfère
lire après ce qui s'est dit mais
regardez je sais vous allez regarder ce
qui va se dire là maintenant ah ben là
je